long before last week's despicable siege
of capital of the capital we were
warning you
that the democrats were gearing up for a
campaign
of retribution against conservatives
banned blocked and purged social media
is taking on conservatives and free
speech
big tech is ramping up the war on
conservative thought ahead of 2020.
well what's their true goal blunting
trump's digital momentum it's obvious
they all mouth platitudes about loving
diversity
but increasingly they want none of it
meaning they want
conservatives banished all together from
the public square
instead of actually convincing people
that you were right and they were wrong
it's shutting them down and taking away
their livelihoods
well i still remember when liberals were
liberal
when they distrusted big corporations
and they supported debate and dialogue
but long before trump
they gave up on trying to persuade
political foes
and they decided instead to persecute
them
silence them demonize them and with the
rise of big
tech they now have powerful ideological
allies
to help do just that now both twitter
and facebook have banned president trump
and the twitter alternative parlor you
probably heard about this lost its home
on amazon web services the dnc media of
course they
try to avoid the question of monopoly
power altogether
this is a private company we hear a lot
of free speech arguments here this is
not the government doing this this is
twitter a private company there's a very
different
issue of censoring if you're a
government entity
versus a private company making a
decision that
you know you may have crossed the line
with the privilege of using
our service yes that's very important
context here
this is not a first amendment battle
well but the media they're answering an
argument that no one on the right is
really making we obviously know that
facebook apple and twitter etc
are private companies ryan
we know that the bill of rights doesn't
apply to private companies and
when we use the term free speech free
expression
we're speaking here metaphorically if
they can get that concept not literally
the problem is that most participants on
both sides
are trying to fit their arguments into a
libertarian framework
in which policymakers should only
concern themselves with government
action and in that case private actors
should just be able to do whatever they
want
but it's been obvious for a long time
that this framework no longer
works for most of the problems that we
now face
private companies in the united states
have too much power
many with market caps larger than the
gdp
of our closest allies so much so that
they can interfere with our national
interests
in all sorts of ways by selling
technology
and shipping jobs to china they can
strengthen our major geopolitical foe
by promoting anti-american ideologies
they can create the type of tensions
that explode into riots and protests on
the left
and the right then by pouring billions
of dollars into our politics
these companies can effectively corrupt
our entire system
and by purging opposing voices off the
internet altogether
they can sow further political divisions
and distort the political debate
in the country